o pulso ao domingo é mais um vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma
armadilha para vocês apanharem os ratos
lá de casa saiu de matarem ou seja
depois de você os apanhar e vocês devem
deixar hoje em liberdade e primeiro
andar uma garrafa com esta aparência
curvada corta em três lados deixando um
para permitir o flash desta parte que eu
vou chamar tampa contenha que será uma
coisa tal e que com cuidado
porém nós pessoas ajudam o duto ok faz
os branquinhos em lados opostos é maio
de tampa na esquina considerar um palito
e se usar um político é usado por comer
comida chinesa
vocês podem usar outra coisa qualquer
poder usar que o político do churrasco
novara qualquer coisa passa um lado a
outro da tampa e ficam duas extremidades
mais ou menos de dois centímetros de
fora é fácil um buraquinho estado mesmo
funda tampo passa um lado ao outro
porque tem que ser pequenino e depois
aumenta e do outro lado porque é
provável que vocês não consigam fazer um
lado ao outro e digo isto porque porque
os bonequinhos tem que ser muito
pequenos com os pacientes só para passar
um clipe
veja aqui a plataforma e atenção aos
bonequinhos de um buraco da garrafa está
mais à frente do que a plataforma é o da
plataforma até ficar um pouco mais pra
de modo a incluir desta maneira bastante
simples
e vão encaixar na plataforma no orifício
da plataforma primária depois o sobrado
fora
vocês vão durar por d
agora se eu clico não ficar bem fixo
vocês podem por um crime de cola
mas se vocês votarem bem acho que não é
preciso agora nós aprender é plataforma
na garrafa e usac fita é os animais
comprar sua casa só para vocês
perceberem nos 3 a 1 no pulsar do
elástico elástico do escritório e depois
prendam desta maneira na extremidade do
político haitiano e prendeu o elástico
do outro lado usando fita
para finalizar vão estar no lugar em
pizza minério bastante simples
já foi tarde ele agora é só arrumar
passar um clipe no outro passar pelo
primeiro edifício e depois pelo orifício
de tanta aí o ilustre me dado fica de
fora linné tampa tem que ter mais ou
menos de dois centímetros por se ver -
não vai conseguir prender tampa e ele
não vai conseguir ficar armadilha armada
é produzir chefe vocês cortam se não
chegar vocês vão ter que usar outro
clique e veja pronto agora o texto
mas uma coisa só está a medida é muito
sensível porque porque o sistema de
alavanca ou seja à medida que o animal
vai avançando para dentro armadilha vai
ficar mais sensível então vai conseguir
apanhar pratos de todo tipo e isso
chegamos ao fim o esperto nenhum estado
e vocês gostaram mesmo e chegou sozinha
o vosso favorito e se inscreva no canal
que isso ajuda bastante a divulgação
evolução do meu trabalho isso um grande
abraço e até a próxima
que tal